naja ich weiß sorgen aber eben was ja
interessant ist ist das sollte war ja
jetzt sehr harmonisch nicht und alle
fragen sich doch jetzt bleibt das so
harmonisch wird die ampel die ganzen
zeit durchhalten die ampel parteien
selbst wollen natürlich möglichst lange
regieren und auch möglichst harmonisch
regieren weil sie jede art von chaos
würde natürlich bei den landtagswahlen
sehr negativ auffallen aber ich glaube
trotzdem dass diese harmonie ziemlich
bald getrübt wird einfach aus einem
zentralen grund wenn man den
koalitionsvertrag durchliest dann ist
der ja sehr ambitioniert also sehr viel
klimaschutz
es soll aber auch was für die
kindergrundsicherung getan werden und so
weiter aber nirgendwo bei all diesen
maßnahmen steht und wie ein preisschild
also es ist völlig unklar wie viel das
eigentlich alles kosten soll wo auch
eine obergrenze ist
gleichzeitig ist auch in großen teilen
unklar wo das geld herkommen soll also
es gibt natürlich so tricks rund um die
schuldenbremse dass das ich jetzt hier
mal weg weil das zu kompliziert wurde
technisch aber auch da ist nicht klar
wie viel sollen jetzt die einzelnen
maßnahmen bringen das heißt insgesamt
weiß man gar nicht wie viele milliarden
stehen zur verfügung gleichzeitig gibt
es aber die schlüssel die schon extrem
teuer sind weil die fdp hat ja
durchgesetzt und ich muss wirklich sagen
ich bin entsetzt dass es 2022 und 2023
so eine so genannte super abschreibung
für die unternehmen geben soll und die
ist relativ unspezifisch man muss nur
irgendwie im klimaschutz investieren und
irgendwie ins digitale das kann aber
jedes unternehmen immer sagen die müssen
ja nur irgendwie ein bisschen ihre
energie effizienz steigern dann haben
sie ja schon in klimaschutz investiert
das heißt sie können eigentlich alle
ihre anschaffung irgendwie dann
abschreiben und dass die idee hat schon
kalkuliert dass das insgesamt ungefähr
40 milliarden kostet das geld ist dann
aber weg und ist geschenkt worden und
unternehmen die das nicht brauchen und
also wenn das die politik ist nicht dass
man eigentlich irgendwie mit der
gießkanne geld zum fenster rausschmeißt
ohne gleichzeitig zu sagen
wie man eigentlich sein
wirklich wichtigen klimapolitischen
ziele dann finanzieren will wird das ein
problem und noch letzter satz also und
weil ich da habe ich mich man merkt ja
schon ich bin total aufgeregt und da
habe ich mich auch aufgeregt nicht also
da hat dann lindner als der
koalitionsvertrag vorgestellt wurde am
mittwoch erzählt man hätte die breite
mitte entlastet also die normalbürger
das ist die breite mitte das stimmt
nicht für die breite mitte wird genau
gar nichts getan alles geld und wirklich
viele milliarden kriegen nur die reichen
und die unternehmer und das finde ich
auch wirklich hanebüchen dass sich ein
finanzminister dahin stellt bei einer
pressekonferenz und lügt er kann ja
sagen ich bin da total dafür die
unternehmer zu entlasten und ich
interessiere mich auch nur für
unternehmer und die kriegen jetzt hier
40 milliarden beschlossen
dass man sich da hinstellt und einfach
knallhart die wahlbürger belügt aber
nicht ein europa der bürger für sie als
reich weil sie sagen hat die reichen
eben wenn man es sein wenn man
investieren kann und abschreiben kann
heißt das dass man ein unternehmen hat
mit ungefähr und sie müssen ja jetzt nur
die unternehmen in deutschland angucken
dann haben sie ein ungefähres bild wie
das so läuft das normale unternehmen das
diese groß geschenke da in anspruch
nehmen kann hat ungefähr
550 500 tausende von mitarbeiter das ja
und damit man auch den eindruck bekommt
wie das in deutschland läuft ein prozent
der firmen in deutschland haben
kontrollieren 67 prozent des umsatzes
und diese eine prozent dass da wundert
sich kurz und die familienunternehmen in
deutschland unser rückgrat sind also
erleben von licon champion das ist
unsere ja ja und die sind haben alle
sehr reich so dass es das kann ich ihnen
gerne er nachweisen wenn sie das hören
möchten aber das normale
familienunternehmen hat im durchschnitt
500 mitarbeiter da ist man nicht arm
sondern da ist man vielfacher millionär
und kriegt jetzt 40 milliarden geschenkt
und leistet also ich auch sehr sehr viel
also etwa deswegen kann man ja so oder
so ich würde schon sagen hier will ich
nochmal gewidmet hinzufügen dass wir
wirklich in deutschland das ist unser
großes gut als deutsch dass wir diese
hidden champion haben die sind übrigens
nicht wie man sich jetzt reiche
vorstellt in münchen auf der
maximilianstraße und ihrem unternehmen
sei am meisten sind kleine regionen wo
sie wo und auch für die mitarbeiter
meistens viel erfolgreicher sind alles
konzerne zb der mitarbeitern sind und
ich muss wirklich sagen wir brauchen die
familien unternehmen und wir sollten
stolz auf unsere familienunternehmen in
deutschland sein
kurbeln das war dann eine davon der
vorstellung dies da gegeben hat was mir
aufgefallen war und sie haben es als
lüge bezeichnet dass christian lindner
von allen die dort standen
definitiv rhetorisch am begabtesten ist
in der freien rede wie er so manche
leute mögen auf dem stil von robert
haben oder dass man habe im ohr der
zuhörer der sehr philosophieren daher
kam der den schönen satz gesagt aber
vorher mit einem recht das steht nicht
drin wo das geld herkommen soll das
stimmt und habe gesagt wir haben uns
fest vorgenommen
wie wir das finanzieren
danach sah zwar aber euch sagen es nicht
jetzt können wir das habe glaube ich
dass durch bei den grün ich mal da gibt
es den parteitag dann gab es den streit
darüber sprechen wir danach noch um die
ministeriums posten dass die so wenig
durchgesetzt haben am ende sorgt das 50
ich glaube in der frage die frau
herrmann anspricht über diese super
abschreibung also die idee ist ja alle
sind sich einig wir müssen viel den
klimaschutz investieren und jetzt gibt
es ja zwei wege entweder der staat sagt
wir sagen euch wo das gemacht wird dann
die von herrn köppel verehrten berater
beamte würden das von vorschreiben oder
die unternehmer gucken wo investieren
sie in diesen weg geht jetzt die ampel
davon vorher machen ganz schrecklich ja
aber eigentlich und differenziert aber
in den grünen hier sind die in
wirklichkeit auch gespalten also es gibt
grüne die sagen unternehmen sind böse
und das soll alles der staat vor scham
aber es gibt auch unternehmen die sagen
wir gibt auch grüne die sagen wir werden
das nur schaffen wenn wir die
wachstumskräfte wenn wir die
innovationskräfte wenn wir auf die
unternehmen sehr dass ein köpfen fest
machen wer jetzt bei den grünen
sozusagen anti und also zum beispiel der
neue finanzminister von baden
württemberg erst daniel bahrs das ist
niemand der die baden-württembergischen
eden champions die sie so verehren
enteignen will weil der weiß ist die
steuern zahlen und dass diese neuen kram
erfinden und davon gibt es eine ganze
menge in grün gibt aber auch die anderen
die freunde von vorher also da sind die
grünen
also ich fühle mich hier gerade
missverstanden ich bin aber das liegt
vielleicht daran dass ich mich noch
nicht deutlich genug ausgedrückt habe
ich bin nicht dagegen dass unternehmen
die in klimaschutz investieren
abschreiben können nur genau so wird es
bei der super abschreibung nicht
funktionieren die ist nämlich für die
jahre 2022 und 2023 das heißt das sind
jetzt kurzfristig wirkende instrumente
wo man nicht sagen kann was ja sinnvoll
wäre nicht dass zum beispiel wenn ein
großunternehmen in ladesäulen für
elektroautos investiert dass sie das
abschreiben können oder wenn sie ihr
insel utoya aber alle anderen können
auch über das wird man ja nicht so genau
spezifizieren können wenn man das will
auch zwei jahre und wenn jetzt jemand
sehen ich denke meine werkshalle im
sinne des klimaschutz auch gut und ja
aber man kann auch zum beispiel sagen
man kauft eine maschine die es energie
effizienter als bisher das in maschinen
aber immer nicht die sind jedes mal
energieeffizienter das ist der ist ja ja
das ist aber der sinn von technischen
fortschritt das haben die bisher alleine
bezahlt wird das ein bisschen um musik
apple der ist so still
ich würde damit groß mit großem
interesse auf der seite von frau herman
grund
kenne mich ja sehr gute heime ich haben
uns heute zum ersten mal kennen gelernt
aber sie sind da schon ganz tief drin
nein aber man muss einfach so in zehn
prozent der wohlhabendsten leute und
auch der unternehmer in deutschland
zahlen etwa wird das ein 70 bis 80
prozent
nicht alle steuern zehn prozent der
wohlhabenden jetzt will ich natürlich
von der position ausgehen dass man
diesen unternehmen und den reichen immer
noch mehr geld wegnehmen kann und die
man noch mehr belasten ich bin nicht so
reich ich finde ich zwar hätten und
das ganze dann
dann werden sie die die milchkühe die
hier die steuern bezahlen die werden sie
irgendwann schlachten oder vertreiben
und das ist gefährlich diese drei aller
schweizer risiko also ich meine sie
haben in der schweiz dadurch massiv
steigende immobilienpreise weil sehr
viele wohlhabende deutsche natürlich in
die schweiz kommen weil sie angst haben
dass diese ganze klimapolitik diese
energiepolitik indem sie die
industrielle arbeitgeber unmöglich und
ich glaube musiker nachbaus nach von der
linken seite dass man das dass man das
nicht wie man sie endlich unterbricht
und manche für ihn auch wegen der
identitätspolitik
unternehmer ist noch nicht so groß
wir haben noch nicht so eine riesige
abwanderung dass wir jetzt keine
unternehmer also die ich treffe die
fühlen sich immer ganz gut
das kann das nicht stehen lassen dass
herr köppel völlig falsche darstellungen
über das deutsche steuersystem hier
verbreitet weil es nämlich so ist dass
die
viele unternehmer zahlen nur die
kapitalertragsteuer die sind nicht in
der progression die kapitalertragssteuer
ist nur bei 25 ich kann ihnen dass ihr
könnt ihn jetzt ein riesen vortrag
halten wollen sie nicht aber die die
oecd hat festgestellt wer in deutschland
am meisten steuern zahlt und
sozialabgaben in bezug auf seine eigene
als auch sein eigenes einkommen und das
sind sie in die singles die 60 60.000 im
jahr haben die haben eine belastung von
60 prozent während wichtig genau eine
belastung von